foreign
just the beginning ahead of more NHS
strikes in England in the coming days
one nursing union now says disruption
could double in size next month if pay
talks don't progress for a government
facing another week locked into several
disputes in several sectors no change in
position this Minister simply warning
walkouts would affect patients we have
to put detailed contingency plans in
place working with the NHS and Health
Service managers to make sure we can
still deliver
Safe Care even on days when there are
strikes but there is clearly an impact
when significant numbers of Staff don't
come to work
but could that impact be Graver during
ambulance strikes the health secretary
has said during recent walkouts not all
unions agreed to put cover in place for
some serious 999 calls including chest
pain and suspected Strokes in the letter
to the GMB Union Steve Barkley said I
want to be absolutely clear that my
colleagues across government and I
greatly value the vital work ambulance
workers do that being said during recent
action I have not been reassured that
the current system of voluntary
Arrangements can be relied upon to
ensure patient and Public Safety our
reps had worked tirelessly with the
ambulance trusts about making sure that
there was emergency provision in place
we were commended by the employers for
the way that this has happened and the
results of it was on the first day the
ambulance dispute you were more likely
to be picked up if you had a serious
issue and quicker
this row comes as MPS prepare to debate
controversial new laws that would
enforce minimum service levels on strike
days in sectors like health and
education the risk for the government is
this all sours the mood of pay talks and
leads unions to escalate their action no
specifics from the labor leader on how
he would avert strikes securma today
saying dysfunction in the NHS means an
overhaul is now needed you will always
have whether it's the NHS or any other
public service people say well don't do
it it's always been done this way
they're nearly always wrong of course
there will be you know challenges
whatever you reform something but
frankly if you don't reform the NHS then
I fear it will die
and schools could be next following
walkouts in Scotland education unions in
England and Wales will announce ballot
results on Monday with other unions also
considering action we do have to have a
reality joke here if you're a graduate
with a good degree what will make you
want to go into teaching you we have to
do something to address what is
essentially teachers being paid 23
percent less now in real terms than they
were back in 2010. one glimmer of hope
may be on the trains with a new offer
expected to be made to workers this week
rail unions are warning against an
abundance of optimism though little to
be certain about it seems apart from
more disruption Rob Powell Sky News in
Westminster